whenever I leave my house in acton I
make a point of taking a plastic bag
with me so I can pick up litter I don't
just mean beer cans and cigarette
packets I mean discarded newspapers
takeaway containers and banana skins I
even pick up those little black plastic
bags that dog owners leave beside trees
or hanging from railings if I'm with my
children they often run ahead shouting
air and yucky they're embarrassed and
rightly so in contemporary Britain it is
now more socially unacceptable to pick
up litter than it is to drop it the
problem isn't just in our cities drive
along any major road in the country and
you'll see rubbish piling up on the
grass verges walk through an area of
natural beauty and you'll find empty
crisp packets and coca-cola can strewn
on every path beaches that were once the
glittering jewels of our sceptred Isle
have been transformed into all-purpose
waste paper baskets England's green and
pleasant land has become a rubbish tip
does this matter I think it does and not
just because we're polluting our
environment and endangering wildlife it
matters because it sends a message that
we don't care about the common part of
our communities private affluence and
public squalor well I care and I'm sure
millions of others do too what can we do
about it forget about the state the only
solution is to roll up your sleeves and
start picking it up yes it's
embarrassing but not as embarrassing as
seeing our beautiful country with some
of the finest architecture and
landscapes in the world descend into a
third-world slum
you